[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday January
22nd thank you for this shirt I love the
shirt and it is also an excellent
motivator to continue losing weight it's
a little tight
seriously it's my favorite shirt out of
all the shirts I've ever owned I was
planning on starting this survey today
but unfortunately that's going to have
to wait until Wednesday Hank as you know
I write books for teenagers and the
biggest award in the world of books for
teenagers is this thing called the
Prince award which is given out every
year for literary excellence last night
I received a call from the Prince
Committee saying that my new book an
abundance of Katherine's has been
awarded a prince honor for 2007 so that
was nice and really really unexpected
Tara didn't pick up the camera right
when they called but she picked it up
shortly after as a bonus you're about to
hear the voice of the Yeti oh my god oh
my god oh my god are you serious really
ha ha ha
thank you thing thank you saying we're
serious I can't believe it oh my
god really wow wow oh my god guys I
can't believe this thank you guys so
much that did Wow this is John's real
happy dance I'm just like all flustered
I hope they're home they won't even in a
message no don't leave a message hi it's
John Catherines got a prince honor
Catherines is one of the runners up for
the Prince award it gets the silver
medal on it I know no I'm serious
I can't believe it yeah it's phony as
we're recording it for the video blog so
it'll be hilarious on the blog no I'm
not you and I am also I'm also
surprised oh my god I can't believe it
oh no the committee gather committee
called me they were very nice they
wouldn't tell me who won though yeah I
can't believe it so pretty pretty
amazing so yeah
and finally Hank I'd like to say thank
you for the lady lady lady lady lady
lady lady John Green song which is
probably the nicest thing that anyone
has ever done for me in my whole entire
life and by nice I mean hilariously mean
why is it that I equate niceness and
hilarious meanness oh right it's from
growing up in our family I'll see you
tomorrow